un carrusel de las artes
maría carolina piña
[Música]
un placer que estén con nosotros en este
nuevo número de carrusel de las artes
que les presentamos hoy desde las el
musical una gran sala de conciertos a
orillas del río sena que presta sus
alrededores este verano para el arte
contemporáneo
[Música]
iremos a la quinta edición de ley
estática una inmensa muestra de arte
contemporáneo a cielo abierto este año
las obras nos invitan a una reflexión
sobre el medio ambiente y la emergencia
climática fuimos al teatro mojado de
parís donde se presentan la más reciente
versión del musical el rey león que
rinde tributo a la diversidad ya la
cultura africanas en este programa
descubriremos los secretos del antiguo
perú a través de una exposición inédita
sobre machu picchu que puede verse en
parís y que reúne piezas con más de 3000
años de historia y también iremos al
encuentro de las mujeres que hacen hip
hop y que utilizan la música como una
poderosa herramienta de expresión
feminista
no lo sé
a carrusel de las artes se encuentra hoy
en la sede musical una hermosa sala de
conciertos que flota sobre las aguas del
río sena estás en música la será el
escenario para una gran exposición de
arte contemporáneo que durará todo el
verano y que se llama ley estática
[Música]
en la cena musical encontramos un
circuito con las obras de cinco artistas
entre los cuales se encuentra el
brasileño henrique oliveira que vamos a
conocer ya mismo
[Música]
enrique oliveira muchísimas gracias por
regalarnos unos minutos en este musical
para hablarnos de esta obra que presenta
usted hoy aquí se llama des natureza
número 5 que nos dice esta obra que va a
tener una serie de trabajos esta obra
forma parte de una serie de trabajos en
los que reutilizó bloques de madera que
consigo en las calles de sao paulo
porque fueron usados en el sector
industrial realizó esculturas con formas
de árboles que recuerdan la naturaleza
buscó es devolver a ese material la
forma que tenían antes de que las
sacaremos de su lugar de origen a origen
de ese material
[Música]
enrique des natureza número 5 es una
forma de decirnos que la naturaleza
debería retomar el espacio que tenía en
nuestra vida humana en nuestras ciudades
porque se puede ser aunque mis obras no
tienen un significado específico
prefiero que el resultado de mi trabajo
quede abierto a muchas interpretaciones
a usted le pareció eso otra persona
puede tener otra opinión y eso me gusta
pero si retoma muchos de mis trabajos
anteriores
siempre están presentes en las formas de
narices troncos ramas que crecen dentro
de a sí mismas es la idea de un eterno
retorno una especie de callejón sin
salida
nos decía que le gusta que el público
haga su propia interpretación de sus
obras y aquí en francia donde estamos
hemos hablado mucho de la amazonía
brasileña le gustaría que haya una
reflexión también sobre esa destrucción
de la naturaleza en su país natal en
brasil
si el caso de la amazonía es muy
evidente porque una gran reserva
forestal del planeta que está
concentrada allí ninguna otra zona en el
mundo tiene una superficie de selva
tropical tan grande y lamentablemente
hoy en día en brasil hay una mentalidad
muy atrasada que considera que la
amazonía debe ser explotada por eso me
encanta que mi trabajo esté aquí en
parís es una ciudad que tiene un peso
histórico la obra puede dialogar con el
paisaje para mí es interesante y al
mismo tiempo
fue un poco intimidado pero existe
muchísimas gracias enrique oliveira muy
abrigada muy obligado
vamos ahora al corazón de parís para
hablarles de uno de los musicales más
exitosos de todos los tiempos el rey
león' volvió al teatro mogador en una
nueva versión de este cuento lleno de
música de humanismo y de la diversidad
del continente africano
el grito de la sabana africana su
diversidad animal y sus cantos
regresaron con ímpetu a parís el rey
león musical que ha conquistado a 100
millones de espectadores en los últimos
25 años regresó al teatro mogador en una
versión renovada un espectáculo
fascinante para el público y exigente
para los artistas
[Música]
a declinar ya esté en fa con el rey león
es un musical de broadway hay que cantar
bailar actuar pero además de todo eso
tenemos que ser los verdaderos atletas
porque lo más difícil no es cantar el
espectáculo sino cantar lo ocho veces
por semana en el rey león se hablan
siete lenguajes tener a su luz lo ágil y
otras es un espectáculo con mucho
respeto de las culturas africanas estoy
muy orgulloso de formar parte de este
elenco en un momento donde justamente el
respeto el multiculturalismo el vivir
juntos y en paz han estado tan
cuestionados entre los artistas hay
orígenes diferentes colores de piel
distintos es una alegría muy
[Música]
al igual que la película de dibujos
animados la versión teatral del rey
león' rescata los cantos tradicionales
sudafricanos pero utiliza 300 máscaras
de animales y 400 marionetas y vestidos
para representar a los diferentes
personajes del cuento
[Música]
no
en ese récord y si hace clic de petición
no es sólo una reproducción en el
escenario de la película de dibujos
animados es mucho más que eso cada
marioneta cada máscara que llevamos los
actores está hecha con mucha precisión y
sin borrar la presencia humana los
creadores del espectáculo querían evocar
el mundo animal pero que se vieran a los
artistas y sus expresiones es un
espectáculo humanista hasta en ese
aspecto que puede ser un detalle pero
que era importante en este relato ahí
nos damos cuenta de que el rey león' es
una historia muy profunda habla de una
búsqueda existencial en la que cada
quien puede verse reflejado y ahí radica
su éxito
[Música]
hacemos ahora un viaje en el tiempo
hasta el perú antiguo por primera vez
piezas artísticas de las civilizaciones
preincaicas han salido de perú para ser
admiradas en la capital francesa una
muestra e inmersión que reúne más de 200
objetos y que abrió sus puertas a
carrusel de las artes
[Música]
el visitante entra a esta exposición
como si estuviera adentrando a la
ciudadela de machu picchu cumbre y
símbolo del imperio inca machu picchu y
los tesoros de perú reúne casi 200
piezas para entender el extraordinario
desarrollo artístico de los incas y de
las civilizaciones del antiguo perú
[Música]
acá en esta exhibición presentamos 3000
años de desarrollo cultural partimos con
culturas diferentes
chavín cupisnique vicus mochica
lambayeque y chimú hasta los incas esto
se cuenta a través de materiales
maravillosos
cerámicas modeladas esté pintadas
textiles suntuosos este textiles de
plumas tejidos pectorales joyas de oro y
plata y todos estos objetos conforman un
discurso narrativo un sistema visual de
comunicación
en parís pueden admirarse suntuosas
joyas de una gran factura de oro y plata
metales sagrados para los habitantes del
perú antiguo
[Música]
el oro representa al sol el sol
representa el mundo de arriba el mundo
de los dioses es masculino la plata
representa la noche representa la luna
representa lo femenino representa el
mundo de abajo la madre tierra el útero
materno es lo que tenemos que hacer
cuando vemos estas piezas en vez de
mirar una joya como la veríamos en
cualquier joyería en realidad lo que
tenemos que ver es todo el trasfondo de
cómo se hizo con tanta mística pensando
que hacerla de esa forma es lo que
impulsaría al círculo de la vida a que
siempre se está regenerando machu picchu
y los tesoros de perú se completa con
una visita de realidad virtual para una
vertiginosa experiencia en inmersión
a continuación vamos a tomarle la
temperatura al mundo del hip hop y del
rap pero en versión femenina natalia el
y varias asistió a la l 2 p la
convención anual del hip hop y allí
conoció a varios cantantes que
decidieron alzar su voz
[Música]
estamos en el barrio 19 de parís aquí
hemos asistido a la convención l 2p
sobre el hip hop en francia y uno de los
temas que nos interesó particularmente
fue el lugar de las artistas mujeres en
esta industria vamos a buscar a las
raperas francesas
[Música]
no deberíamos hacer cosas que no
queremos sólo para poder expresarse con
nuestra música
[Música]
desde los años 80 siempre han estado
presentes permanecieron invisibles en
los 90 casi una mujer firmó con una gran
productora en la década de 2000
comenzaron a hacerse más visibles entre
2000 15 2017 en la época del movimiento
[Música]
el movimiento hasta actitud también
alcanzó la industria musical con
eslóganes como hasta music tour
punto 2 en la industria de la música las
mujeres están en peligro de manera
general no es una locura decir esto el
porcentaje de mujeres agredidas
moralmente o sexualmente o cuyas
carreras han sido bloqueadas es enorme
[Música]
dónde están las raperas la convención
del hip hop en francia descarta el
término de rap femenino que no ha
servido para la emancipación de las
mujeres para algunas incluso alimentó
una imagen falsa o distorsionada de las
mujeres en el hip hop así cascón del
[Música]
colectivo sam witwer que se le fama en
los vídeos siempre son las mujeres las
que hacen perreo nunca los hombres sin
embargo los hay mostrar que un hombre
puede pelear ni siquiera debería
sorprender o no deberíamos decir que
rompe los códigos
la hipersexualización de las mujeres es
un fenómeno que juega en su contra pero
en realidad también permite a
reapropiarse de su cuerpo sobre todo
cuando hemos sido víctimas de ciertas
cosas o cuando hemos estado cargadas de
prejuicios toda nuestra vida puede
convertirse en una poderosa herramienta
para la autoafirmación tanto artística
como personalmente puede ser más fuerte
pero también hay otras formas de
transmitir el mensaje de la mañana ática
de tendón y valor la forma en que hemos
entrenado las normas los valores y
nuestra percepción de la diferencia es
una construcción social por lo que
significa que podemos cuestionar la y
deconstruir los juegos de acción
no busquen más a las raperas francesas
porque aquí están sus voces y sus
estilos se oyen en la escena alternativa
escaño antes de conquistar el género
musical más escuchado en francia se use
no quieren gracias natal y olivares y
con el tema mons y el de la rapera
isaías u que vamos a despedir este
programa especial de carros de las artes
que les presentamos desde la sede
musical de parís muchísimas gracias por
su sintonía y hasta la próxima
[Música]
loable cultura espacio y aplauso to live
y
de paso
[Música]